- Let me hear some of your English accent.
(both laugh)
- (with phlegmatic accent)
Can I hagh some water?
(RuPaul laughs)
- [Trinity K. Bonet As Nicki
Minaj] Ru, can you get people
that speak normal English
next time for the show?
- Excuse me, we originated the language.
- Ugh!
- Ew!
- [RuPaul] That is a wrap.
(upbeat pop music)
♪ May the best woman win ♪
- Yara Sofia,
- Hi!
- Hola mami!
- Hola!
- [RuPaul] Who do we have here?
- [Yara] Amy Winehouse.
- You're from Puerto Rico.
- Yes.
- She's from England...
- England.
- How are you gonna do that? (laughs)
- Well, I be watching
(with accent) Hatty Potter, so,
- Harry Potter?
- Hatty Potter, yes.
- Let me hear some of your English accent.
(both laugh)
- (with phlegmatic accent)
Can I hagh some water?
(RuPaul laughs)
- [Yara] How was that?
- By George, I think you've got it!
- Oh, really?
- Yes!
- Next to her is England's
gorgeous rock superstar,
Amy Winehouse!
- [Ru Paul] Hey, Amy!
- (with phlegmatic
accent) Hi, how are you?
(RuPaul laughs)
- [RuPaul] I think this
is your first game show
in America, have you done
game shows in England?
- (with accent) Yes, yes,
just a few ones, um, I have.
- Yes.
- [RuPaul] Alright, let's
go to Amy Winehouse.
- [RuPaul] Crazy Daisy
thinks, a Kardashian is a?
- Lubricant remover.
- Lubricant remover!
- [Aisha] That's a great answer, actually,
- [RuPaul] It is a great answer.
- [Aisha] Yeah.
- Unfortunately Aisha, it's not a match.
- [Aisha] No.
(playful piano music)
- Oh-ooo!
- [Milan] Are you doing an accent?
- Yes, a British ac-chent.
- [Milan] It's a little distracting.
Like I think it might
be a little distracting
to the text, but that's your choice.
- I'm an actor and I know
how to portray a character
and that's actually my strength.
- [Madame LaQueer] I asked
the young man next to me
for his napkin to wipe my
friend's sticky beaver.
- Oh my God, that's
gonna be stupid (laughs)
- Action!
- It was so mortifying.
I accidentally spilled a,
(rolls tongue)
- I accidentally spilled
a Virgin Mary on Rose so I
(stumbles over words)
- Cut. It's a Bloody
Mary, not a Virgin Mary.
- Okay.
- And I asked this young
man next to me for a,
(rolls tongue)
I'm gonna go again.
Sorry, so sorry.
- LaQueer, it's really
important that you listen
to the director, okay?
When you make a mistake
and you're in front of a live audience
you gotta keep going.
You keep stopping as if
you're allowed to stop,
there is no stopping.
- So I asked the young man next to me
for a napkin so I can wipe
my friends hairy beaver,
(record scratch)
(awkward horns)
- Oof. Ouch.
- Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
are we talking about beavers or...
Ew!
- Can you do the "ew"
as Lucille Ball though?
(mimics Lucille Ball)
Ewww, do it like that.
- Ew!
- Ugh!
- [RuPaul] That is a wrap.
(funky pop music)
- Hi, Ru.
- It looks like you're
doing someone older.
- It is.
I will be doing Maggie Smith.
- Downton Abbey Maggie Smith.
- Yes.
- How will you make Maggie Smith funny?
(music stops)
- Well I think Maggie Smith is already
such a character.
(foreboding pop music)
- Mm.
- And just, sort of, she's been
in the business so long.
- Yeah.
Now you do an English accent?
- Um, you know, I don't know
how to do one if I'm honest.
- [RuPaul] Dame Maggie Smith is with us.
(audience applauds and cheers)
- How are you, my dear?
- Well, past a certain age
one just feels fortunate
to see the sun rise another day.
(RuPaul and the crowd laugh)
- Yes, Maggie Smith!
- Well now, let's just keep it Mr. Charles
and Dame Smith, shall we?
(audience exclaims)
- Yes, ma'am.
Dame Maggie Smith, Cher
is completely addicted
to social media,
even her "blank" has a Twitter account.
- Well, "Ruple."
Ruple, is it?
(judges and crowd laugh)
- [RuPaul] Yes, absolutely.
- I understood virtually none of the words
that left your lips moments ago
but I did hear the term "Twitter"
and I assume that it's
some sort of a songbird.
(audience laughs)
- [RuPaul] Very close, not a match.
- Am I to understand that
one yanks ones' telephone
right out of the wall
and carries it with them?
(judges and audience laugh)
- [RuPaul] Yes.
- [Trinity K. Bonet As Nicki
Minaj] Ru, can you get people
that speak normal English
next time for the show?
- Excuse me, we originated the language.
(all laugh)
- [Trinity] Oh, okay.
- [RuPaul] Alright, Heather.
That Chelsea Handler is so wrong.
She's launching a new vodka.
It's flavored with "blank."
- Xanax.
(audience laughs)
- [RuPaul] Xanax!
What a great idea!
- Well I'm unfamiliar with
the work of Lady Handler,
however, I did think that
it would be rather amusing
if there were a libation
flavored with citrus (giggles)
(RuPaul laughs)
Can you imagine such a thing?
(audience and judges laugh)
- [RuPaul] That is really new-fangled,
I can't imagine such a thing.
- Yes.
(all laugh)
- Music superstar Adele is here.
Hey girl!
(crowd applauds)
- (attempting a cockney
accent) Could I buy a vowel?
(crowd and judges laugh)
- [RuPaul] What is that, darling?
- No whammies!
- [RuPaul] No, no, no,
this is the wrong show.
- Okay.
(judges laugh)
- Where in England are you from, Adele?
- My house.
(crowd laughs)
- [RuPaul] Alright! Dorothy
"blanks" the tin man.
- Well, if it was me I would
say she rips out his heart
and then sings a whole album about it
and gets really popular, but,
- [RuPaul] Yeah.
- [Ginger Minj As Adele] But it's not me.
- No, no.
- So I said she polishes his chrome.
(judges laugh)
- [RuPaul] It's a good answer,
but not a match, darling.
- But could I get a match, please?
It's a fake cigarette.
(judges laugh)
- Adele! Adele, how much food do you have
down there, girl?
- A smorgasbord.
- I have low sugar.
- [RuPaul] Oh, you have the low sugar.
- [Ginger] And I've got to keep it up.
- She's using my EBT card.
- [RuPaul] Oh, Lord!
(crowd and judges laugh)
- Hoo!
- Hah
- Wrong note, sugar.
(audience laughs)
- [RuPaul] All right, Portia
de Rossi says Ellen is
so hilarious even her
"blank" makes her laugh.
- Sad, sad tears of a clown.
(audience chuckles)
- Yeah, like the Smokey Robinson,
- Yeah.
- Song.
I'm so sorry Adele, that is not a match.
- But it's a song.
- [RuPaul] It is a song!
But it's a,
- Did I sing it?
- [RuPaul] No, you did not
sing it, it's a Smokey,
- So it's not a good song.
(RuPaul laughs)
- Probably still won
an award for it anyway.
(crowd and judges chuckle)
- [RuPaul] Probably, yes.
- [RuPaul] Now, can you do an accent?
- (with a posh accent)
Top of the morning to you.
(other queens laugh)
- Do you want something delicious?
That is succulent, decadent,
hot, and vivacious?
(RuPaul laughs)
- Well you should totally
have RuPaul's Chocolate Bar.
- [RuPaul] That's the worst
Jamaican accent I've ever heard.
(queens laugh)
- [RuPaul] Tell the chocolate
bar what you think of it.
- Oh, you, decadent chocolate bar, you.
(queens laugh)
Succulent!
(RuPaul giggles)